spring 2018 is going to be wild every
rule can be broken especially when it
comes to combining patterns fashion
journalist silky Booker has been in the
business for 12 years with the help of a
model in Dusseldorf's fashion clinic
shop she explains what to expect from
the designer spring and summer
collections
little star kid and a major focus in
fashion right now is actually daring to
break rules combining what seems
uncombined about you can do that really
nicely with materials and patterns in
this case an abstract floral print is
combined with stripes and the stripes
are picked up again on our shoes well
the floral motif shows up again on the
pants another trend wearing many layers
one on top of the other
ideally oversized if you pass this on
you have to be a little careful about
the silhouette so that it looks good as
a whole the blouse can't be too long the
sweater shouldn't be too short you have
to achieve a certain harmony
in terms of color palette the spring
collection could hardly be more fresh
almost all designers are favoring
delicate tones that can be easily
combined on the one hand you've got the
pistols very powdery tones but on the
other you have super glaring colors to
set against those tones what's new is
that these glaring colors can now also
be worn together ten years ago the
complementary colors like purple and
orange couldn't be combined now they can
the louder the crazier the better
that's a motif we're seeing on runway
and another trend that was long scoffed
at is making a comeback double denim
right now almost anything goes when
wearing denim on denim
[Music]
but I love silhouetted in the back
across all the silhouettes you see
pieces of denim that can be combined
even of different washers dark for the
light right now we're also seeing a lot
of denim patchwork beautiful Xena so
momentous patchwork I don't know
here different pieces are put together
to make one pair of trousers and the 90s
are back expect leotards and bathing
suits with high cut legs so feel free to
go out in a shiny tracksuit you can spot
this trend in shop windows of stores
like Melia in düsseldorf city center
here the designer clothes on sale are
pretty daring the 90s influence is
apparent in the transparent synthetic
fabrics and flip-flops
we are the experimentation with logos to
the trend of the 1990s now they're being
used to the grand scale
they aren't hiding them anymore but
boldly putting them right out there
we're taking it all for granted not in a
showy way more stuff confidently yeah
absolutely
spring is also bringing something for
those who prefer design classics the
trench coat is back the 100 year old
classic is getting a makeover
[Music]
the trench coat is a classic and now
they have reinterpreted it with far more
volume so that's the new styling idea
but a trench coat is always a good
investment it's one of my favorite
pieces of clothing you should always
have one in your closet
I am Shankar next to trench coats you'll
also be seeing these transparent
raincoats and at the very least those
will keep you dry and fashionable this
spring in Europe
[Music]